ja ich habe mich heute aufgeregt über
freies for future nicht über die 400.000
menschen die da durch die städte
gelaufen sind auch hier durch berlin
habe mir das selber angeguckt auch viele
viele junge menschen dabei mit treuen
schildern the future is now und selber
planet und alles das sehr berechtigt
aber grundlage dieses ganzen ist ja
dieses neuen protest ist ein bewegender
brief gehen diese bewegungsfreiheit des
verführers den regierungschefs und
staatschefs der welt geschrieben hat
nämlich kreta thonberg und luisa neubau
haben da unterzeichnet und ich habe ihn
gestern noch mal angeguckt wenn andere
diskussionen abgesehen das sind ganz
viele künstler dabei wieder
unterzeichnet haben um ganz vorne billy
eilig die auch bald das klima noch mal
neue konzerte geben politisch wir kennen
sie alle respektieren sie tolle
künstlerin es gab so eine apple doku
über ihr leben daran erinnerte ich mich
dann auf einmal das ist eine apple doku
die zeit diese legt und dann verdient
sie ihr erstes geld und kaufte von
diesem von diesem geld das sie erworben
hat über ihre streaming ein riesen
muscle car schwarz matt lackiert ein
dodge 4 171 ps
versehen werden 18 liter pro 100
kilometer und das ist nun eine ikone der
us future bewegung ich finde es gut ich
habe nichts gegen dieses auto ich finde
sogar ein tolles auto man würde gerne
auch selbst ein solches waren aber jeder
kann freilich auch machen nur dann soll
man sich nicht hinstellen allen fossilen
elementen auf dieser welt abschwören
kohle gas öl und sagen bitte nein weg
damit und dann als ikone dieser bewegung
sein unterschrift darunter setzen und
ein solches auto fahren das finde ich
höchst unglaubwürdig vielleicht hat das
ist diese doppelmoral über die wir
gestern abend in dieser runde auch schon
mal gesprochen haben ganz klar ich
glaube auch dass man bei vielen fridays
for future mitläufern demonstranten
diesen erhobenen zeigefinger durchaus
als stinkefinger in das gesicht aller
normal arbeitenden oder lebenden bürger
empfinden kann oder sogar muss weil
einfach dort propagiert wird
skandalisiert wird etwas was ich so
leicht bei einigen gar nicht ändern
lässt in der stadt kann man gut mit dem
fahrrad fahren auf dem land wird der weg
zum arbeitsplatz dann doch schon ein
bisschen länger mit dem fahrrad nicht so
gut hin zu legen und nicht so viele
ratschläge wie so viele radweg leben
möglicherweise vielleicht gibt es auch
nicht so viele busanbindungen also um
aus diesem freitag futures mitläufern
oder auch demonstranten spricht glaube
ich sehr sehr viel arroganz und das was
mich am stärksten eigentlich beschäftigt
oder da auch empört ist auch die
ablehnung bei vielen des kapitalismus
also echt des systems das diesen
wohlstand überhaupt erst erschaffen hat
und klimaschutz möglich zu machen denn
ohne wohlstand ist klimaschutz gar nicht
finanzieren
klimapolitik ist für mich tschuldigung
der größte betrug die größte ehre
führung der leute weltweit und alle
natürlich der mensch rennt dem hinterher
andrea diesen moskauer fahrenden
teenager idol und
klimapolitik heißt ganz klar grüne
klimapolitik heißt
planwirtschaft ohne plan heißt
selbstverständlich zerstörung der
marktwirtschaftlichen ordnung die grünen
sind für mich keine grünen die sind
tiefrote sozialisten die missbrauchen
die klimapolitik um eine systematische
thema und tasche der marktwirtschaft zu
betreiben schaut euch nur die
wahlprogramme an ich finde das unseriös
das hat auch nichts mit umweltschutz zu
tun ich bin für umweltschutz und meine
umwelt die krone ist nicht kreta
thunberg sondern das ist der
italienische umweltminister ein physiker
der gesagt hat ich bin auch für den
ökologischen umbau der italienischen
wirtschaft aber eben mit
marktwirtschaftlichem methoden mit
technologie und frauen auch mit
kernkraft er und das ist einfach die
diskussion die einen in einem
fortgeschrittenen technologie land wie
deutschland geführt werden sollte und
nicht diese coop wolle
grün rot lackierte
wohlstands ausstiegspolitik der grünen
und das ist etwas was ich bedaure in
diesem jahr kommt dass es den
bürgerlichen nicht gelungen ist diese
grünen zu entzaubern darum müssen wir
das machen in dieser sendung fußball
kamberi ziemlich lange erstmals für dich
oh ich finde erstmals ein geiles auto ja
und ich gönne es ihr ich habe kein
nahezu wieder das auto auch nicht wo ich
mich aber trotzdem noch mal fragen wofür
sich das hart erarbeitet aber leistung
gesprochen und super auto würde auch
gern europa gern erfahren aber es ist
ein bisschen absurd und da wirst du die
klimapolitik auch so ein bisschen dann
angesprochen auch diese dieser deutsche
diskurs in den tri allen erlebt was
wollen sie verbieten was möchten sie
verbieten worauf verzichten sie das war
die fragen wenn wir über klimapolitik
sprechern und das ist ja das absurde das
wird jetzt ja ihr zu vorwurf gemacht
weil sie so eine verzichts rhetorik hat
die industrialisierung kein wachstum
mehr dass alle schlecht aber selbst
eigentlich gar nicht diesen lebensstil
leben möchte sondern den lebensstil und
sagt freien gesellschaft der
marktwirtschaft wo man auch
konsumentscheidungen frei treffen kann
und deswegen ist glaube ich dieser der
weg der moralischen überlegenheit auch
nicht das was das klima global retten
können die meisten länder dieser welt
die können gar nicht auf wohlstand
verzichten sondern die entscheidende
frage ist können wir wohlstand
erwirtschaften mit technologien
fortschritt marktwirtschaft ingenieur
und dann können wir weltmeister werden
und nicht mit mit nämlich ja nun
konsequenzen weil man immer denkt wir
schauen nur auf uns wie groß ist asozial
da stimme ich eher zu uns vor allem ist
die groß also zeit für die
entwicklungsländer auch also die
brauchen noch mehr unser markenkern aber
die groth also das
aber es hat auch noch mit la geklappt
dass man die roma aktionismus so mehr
erleichtern kann genau mit schrumpft
werden hat noch nie geklappt also etwas
rum ja kann ja nicht ein mehrwert heraus
entstehen sonst kann immer nur ein
mehrwert entstehen wenn auch irgendwo
mehrwert produziert wird ganz simpel
klingt in taiwan aber es ist so heißt
das ab und ihrer klimapolitik beim
läuten wenn ich weniger es werde ich
nicht dicker in der regel nicht das
heißt wenn ich irgendetwas bewirken
möchte muss sich auch input möglich
machen muss wachsen und gibt ja auch
viele ingenieure die wollen auch für
ihre tollen leistungen bezahlt werden
die brauchen auch ein bisschen mehr lohn
allein schon das lohnplus muss ich ja
aus wachstum bezahlen also da geht es
schon los ich muss mir neue technologien
auch leisten können das geht nicht wenn
ich sage alle menschen weniger geld
menschen müssen mehr geld haben um sich
zum beispiel auch ein solardach lassen
woher soll der strom kommen in zukunft
wenn sich alle einen tesla kaufen so
noch ein gedanke ich finde das fast
schon obszön
wie die das sehr guter satz von
christian lindner gewesen also gesagt
warum subventionieren wird elektroautos
wisst ihr wo diese subventionen landen
die laut die landen im portemonnaie von
elon musk dem reichsten man diese werte
der wir mit den deutschen elektro
subventionen noch reicher gemacht ich
gratuliere für diese wunderbare
ökologische politik des wahnsinns meinen
arm und es geht ja noch weiter wir haben
ein abkommen geschlossen
von unterschiedlichen polen ja aber wir
treffen uns irgendwo das da ist wurde
ein abkommen geschlossen das beben kurz
gefeiert damit unter der decke zwischen
außenminister und wirtschaftsminister
heiko maas und peter altmaier konkret
mit bolivien und wir sind stolz darauf
dass wir ein abkommen unterzeichnet
haben zur ausbeute von seltenen erden
wir brauchen eben für die
elektromobilität aus bolivien
wogegen sich der damalige frühere
staatschef immer gewertet weil diese
seltenen erden in der salar de uyuni
entstehen das ist nämlich der größte
salzsee rang größten selten und im
naturwunder dieser welt und das wird ja
alles schön auf geflucht und ausgeburt
eine versündigung an der natur und wir
sagen wunderbar dass wir uns diese
vorräte gesichert 80 unglaublich das
sieht man auch in deutschland übrigens
diese diese tesla fabrik da werden ja
ganze welt um für windräder könnt ihr
jetzt auch bäume abhacken ja ich bin
noch mit dem waldsterben groß geworden
da wurde ich auch grün bis ich gemerkt
haben dass ist das waldsterben gar nicht
da haben wir doch wie ich gerade die
werden aber dabei und sieht für die
klimapolitik auf die ganze welt roten ja
das ist doch gespann entschuldigung es
ist auch wir haben gestern saß auf dem
platz wo jetzt hat trainer sitzt georgia
low der
cdu-kandidat in berlin-spandau und
mitglied im kompetenz und auch
zukunftsteam von armin laschet und da
ging es auch um das thema kernkraft und
er musste oder gab nachher aus freien
stücken zu dass a der ausstieg erst
kernkraft zu beenden und dann kohle
erstmal in der falschen reihenfolge war
und überhaupt auch aus der kernkraft
auszusteigen aus einer co2
emissionsfreien
energie auszusteigen also ein fehler an
sich ist und es sinnvoller wäre den
kohleausstieg vorzuziehen
besser für das klima für den
schadstoffausstoß und eine technologie
zu investieren die ja viel weiter ist
als 86 tschernobyl also das ist ja 40
jahre hat sich etwas getan die bei und
wir sehen auch wenn gestern auf heute
haben wir noch nicht dass ein solches
profil aber wir haben auch im heutigen
mit aber wir haben das niemand ist so
lange als bei roche knapp und die nein
aber wir haben wir haben aber ein
problem auch nicht gelöst deswegen kann
man und da gibt es gibt ja auch projekte
die arbeiten beispielsweise daran weg
und die reaktoren die zum einen viel
weniger sondermüll oder radioaktiven
müll produzieren es gibt eine kolumne
von jahren immer noch strahlt es gibt
entwicklungen dass die reaktoren mini
reaktoren den zum teil dann selbst auch
mal wieder nutzen um daraus energie zu
schaffen also was ich nur sagen wird ist
es gibt ein problem vollkommen richtig
aber was ist das größere problem ich für
immer wenn man nichts tut also
klimaschutz kann gar nicht teuer genug
sein weiter die alternative noch teurer
wäre also wenn man es wirklich ernst
meint dann müsste man doch sagen raus
aus der kohle und zwar schnell und eine
emissionsfreie energie nutzen denn wir
wissen auch kohle und atomkraft
kernkraft haben im ersten halbjahr 40
prozent der deutschen energie noch
gebracht und wir brauchen bis 2030
zusätzlich 25 prozent mehr energie wir
haben also diese große energie schlug
vor ungefähr 50 prozent der wir uns dann
berauben tja dann können wir hier auch
im dunklen studio selten vielleicht
kommst du mit einem atomendlager wir
müssen das problem lösen grund ist dass
noch was noch hinzukommt also ist
eigentlich eine binsenweisheit dass wir
zu früh ausgestiegen sind und wir den
zweiten schritt vor dem ersten gemacht
hat jetzt kann ich wieder sagt ja schon
fast jeder die arbeit meinung dass das
zweite was ich sagen wollte was wir auch
nochmals der debatte damals lernen da
wurde gesagt okay wenn deutschland
aussteigt dann folgen uns die länder
dieser welt die folgen und im theater
ist das gegenteil ist kein erfolg dem
land mit dem ströme mit den höchsten
strompreisen fast in europa ist
landesweit schon die anderen bauen und
kernkraftwerk und ich glaube wir sollten
die sind fehler nicht wieder machen dass
wir glauben länder folgen uns aufgrund
von moralischer über los sondern denn
die es am besten hinkriegen und das
haben wir damit gemacht und ich habe
gerade die sorge dass wir erst bei den
wichtigen thema aus meiner sicht und das
haben sie auch gesagt ja für
umweltschutz und bei den wichtigen thema
des klimaschutzes wieder die nur mit
moral argumentieren anstatt wirklich in
der praxis wie können wir das um was ist
die groteske nummer eins seit man diese
forcierte planwirtschaftliche energie
ausstiegspolitik diese klimapolitik
haben erleben wir dass der kohlestrom
eine konjunktur erlebt das gas der
gaspreis geht durch die ecke durch die
decke der ölpreis geht durch die decke
die chinesen bauen weil sich zu hause
ein kohlekraftwerk nach dem anderen im
ausland nicht mehr und jetzt ist die
kone die kosten erschwingliche
energieträger vor und wir haben mehr co2
emissionen aufgrund der klimapolitik das
ist die absurdität der planwirtschaft
ohne plan und da haben freies for future
genau den punkt und da bin ich
tatsächlich bei denen also wenn ich mit
ihm bin ich das höre was du sagst dann
brauchen wir nur weitere kohlekraftwerke
nein da bin ich dagegen dabei
und dann ja schon den tollen energiemix
und die sagen wir kommen weiter mit
einer solchen politik zu einem anstieg
des weltklimas wir müssen etwas tun ich
glaube wir brauchen eine
brückentechnologie nächsten 30 40 50
jahre es gibt stoffe die man als ersatz
auch umweltschonend einsetzen kann es
gibt es gibt gas nicht nur grünes gas
sondern auch normal es eben was sie
einsetzen können für den wasserstoff
förderung und dergleichen also wir
brauchen aber eine brückentechnologie
bis wir das dann wettbewerb
[Musik]